[Applaudissements]
mode avec un couturier qui a su faire de
son prénom une marque prestigieuse
Valentino le styliste italien fêté ce
weekend à Rome les 45 ans d'existence de
sa maison de haute couture des
festivités démesurées avec des invités
de luxe à Rome Estelle Collin et Sylvain
Gautier premier à fouler le tapis rouge
star parmi les stars Valentino Gina
Mick fara t Go ne jure que par Lui
est-ce qu'il est le meilleur
écoutez bien sûr bien sûr que c'est le
meilleur même Armani et Lagerfeld sont
de la fête du jamais vu c'est quelqu'un
qui suit pas la mode il est il
est fidèle à lui-même et c'est comme
cela depuis
1968 Jackie Kennedy épouse Aristote onis
elle porte une robe Valentino le myth
est lancé le petit Valentino Garavani
impose son style glamour son bronzage
son broching impeccable et son rouge ce
vermillon incendiaire dont le couturier
détient pratiquement aujourd'hui la
propriété
intellectuelle cétait tellement évident
que dans chaque collection je mettais du
rouge que automatiquement les tous les
les fabricants de tissu il le rouge
Valentin parce que moi je Donis toujours
ce rouge strict discipliné obsédé de
perfection le couturier est aujourd'hui
au sommet de sa carrière c'est ça qui me
donne beaucoup de joie et surtout
beaucoup
de force pour continuer toutes ces
dernières années j'ai été vraiment comme
un bouldoza quel âge avez-vous ah ça on
dit pas l'â vous savez surtout en France
on le dit pas en Italie tous les 5
minutes mais vous la connaissez vous
ouvrez
un magazine et vous avez bon âge 76 ans
un bel âge pour rentrer au musée hommage
un peu comme toutes ces
aigériies ces vêtements sont tellement
élégants tellement féminins c'est
presque un privilège
ir à chez lui
et inroable Valen V une vie très ch je
l'imagine pas une seconde sortant de la
salle de bain avec un to à la main chez
lui tout est parfait et c'est ce que
nous
voulons son style majestueux Royal comme
l' le monde de Valentino o tout ce qui
brille est en or massif PAV diamant de
préférence
tout est fluide tout coule de source un
peu comme son
inspiration c'est presque ridicule à
dire je peux dessiner une collection une
vingtaine de jours il dit qu'il arrêtera
lorsqu'il en aura assez autant dire
jamais cinéma